so if I asked you what is your number
one challenge more likely than not you
would tell me it's that I lack time I
have too many things to do and not
enough time to do it I have too many
goals and not enough time
so social psychologists have found that
we have multiple parts of ourself and in
fact we have multiple parts of ourselves
they're often associated with different
goals so for example pretend you want to
be a great athlete you also want to
excel at your work you also want to be a
great partner and each of these parts of
cells have their own goals associated
with them now the problem is sometimes
these goals start to compete with each
other and when you limited time and
resources the question becomes can you
reframe time such that you can achieve
multiple goals at the same time so for
example if you want to volunteer at a
non-profit could you have a friend come
along if indeed being a good friend and
also giving back to the community are
both important goals you share if you're
going to go on a run because you bring
your partner with you if indeed being a
good partner and being an athlete are
two important goals to you so the
question is can you create a single
activity and make it become a double or
a triple or homerun what are those
activities in life that satiate multiple
parts of yourself and still allow you to
attain the goals you want to do and
before you say yes or no to any activity
ask yourself can I make this a double or
a triple or a homerun and in fact
research shows that most all of us have
homeruns in our life we just don't
necessarily code activities in that way
a multiplier is a single activity that's
done and fulfills multiple goals it's
different than multitasking multitasking
is when you're doing multiple activities
to satiate multiple goals and you're not
being fully present a multiplier is a
single activity done to fulfill multiple
goals and as a result you're fully
present the first part of the research I
used was the multiplier and it started
simply with just go on a walk with my
spouse talk a little bit about work and
then I would go out to coffee with a
friend and then we thought let's go on a
walk as well and I kept on thinking how
could I continue to combine ideas
together that made more goals achievable
versus the idea that I had before of
multitasking which made me feel very
divided I'm a single mom I work
full-time and I go to school at night to
get my MBA I realized I couldn't do it
all I was doing homework here doing
homework on my lunch hour homework on
the weekends and I realized my daughter
and I are both in school I want to spend
time with her so we do our homework
together it allows me the time to
reconnect with her and to show that
education is important understanding the
power of multipliers I've really
encouraged my team to take on activities
at work that address multiple dimensions
so for example I've encouraged one of my
reports to get involved in the Women's
Committee we have at work which gives
her great visibility into other parts of
the business introduces her to a network
of women and allows her to leverage the
expertise she's developed in our
department on projects she wouldn't
otherwise be involved in when we feel
overwhelmed we often feel like we need
to sacrifice schools but instead of
giving up on certain goals might we
rethink time can we use these tools to
become more time affluent